but
i'm not gonna share what you shared with
me i don't even remember
but he touched me
ben having a chance to play in the
playoffs
after like
winning the playoff game like getting a
chance to throw a touchdown in the
playoffs like
i love football
that's all i i've done my entire life
and someone that i look up to
that i admire that i have to
could touch
was my teammate and i had a chance to
serve him
like man this
i'm speechless that like they
that really gets me emotional
because i really love drew brees like
i don't think he understands
i know my wife do i know my family do
but
yeah i don't understand the impact
that him and a lot of other quarterbacks
had on me
as a quarterback
growing up
in bessemer alabama
and y'all don't never understand like a
lot of people don't understand that
human aspect to an athlete but
no man
just know i love drew brees for real
like i really do
my goodness that
that was surprising and powerful and i
i'm choosing to smile otherwise i
will start crying myself high emotion
from just one year the jameis winston
and drew brees were on the same team
obviously they knew each other five
years before that when winston was the
quarterback of the buccaneers but shows
you the impact that brees had on winston
now winston's staying with the saints
his contract would suggest
he's not the guy who is penciled in as
the starter but
contract doesn't matter the best guy is
going to play and i know there's been
some reports that winston has a leg up
on the job i think hill acquitted
himself pretty well last year but i i i
was taken aback by winston's emotion
and this is a guy who's still maturing
he's only spent six years in the nfl
he's done some very good things he was
an mvp candidate in 2016.
he does have a 5 000 yard season
and
sean payton is a magician when it comes
to working with quarterbacks so
i'm i'm very curious to see how it plays
out and i have a much different feeling
about jameis winston after seeing that
minute and a half than i did
before boy i'm with you mike that was
emotional and powerful and and uh really
cool by jameis winston you can see the
impact that drew brees had on him in the
last year and hopefully in a very
positive way i do think jameis winston
has matured i do think he will be better
under sean payton and frankly i expect
the saints to figure out a way to play
both quarterbacks i don't know if it'll
quite be like the roger stalbot craig
morton let's sub him out every series
every play
those sorts of things but i do think
both quarterbacks will get a big chance
to play for the saints this year and
sean payton will figure out how to use
both to the best of uh their advantage
and in his advantage
many in the media thought winston would
replace brees when brees had 28 broken
ribs earlier in the season and when it
was hill that surprised folks but at the
same time it was winston who came in to
throw that pass based on the play they
borrowed from the chicago bears in the
playoff loss to the tampa bay buccaneers
it was winston who got the assignment
not hill so we'll see however it plays
out
sean payton is going to keep
his intentions secret as long as he can
and we'll know when he wants us to know
who the starter is going to be he's
proven he's capable of pulling that off
as well
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports